I think we are all responsible for the
environment and all of our various roles
so I'm a dad I'm responsible for the
environment with my children educating
them having them understand this is a
dolphin this is a starfish these are
coastal issues this is pollution this is
what you should do about it etc but I'm
also responsible in my professional life
whatever that is to get engaged etc and
I'm also responsible for holding my
government to task for their
environmental regulations and procedures
etc it's not enough and it's
unacceptable for us to just say oh
that's their issue Oh
state will take care of that oh my
County government should that's their
problem
that's lame and it's essentially just
takes you back and it wait just takes
you out of the picture if you want to be
in the picture if you want to have a
voice take the voice and act and stop
complaining
I believe that individuals can change
the world in fact I believe that
individuals do change the world every
single day I believe that every one of
our individual choices collectively
moves the network it shifts value it
shifts culture and so in that sense
individuals the ones that are buying
Pepsi products or Coke products or
whatever whatever our consuming habits
are the ones that are spending this much
on electricity because they didn't you
know buy double pane windows etc all of
our habits shift Society so absolutely I
believe that the individual has that
power